حضور كبير لفيلم كاندهار على شاشات
السينما العالميه وهو اول فيلم عالمي تم
تصويره وتنفيذه في السعوديه تحديدا في
محافظه العلا الفيلم من بطوله جورج
وداع عرضه في الصلاه منذ الخميس الماضي
يحكي الصراع الاستخباراتي بين الاجهزه
الامريكيه والبريطانيه والايرانيه
والباكستانيه ويتناول وقائع حديثه منها
تفجير معمل نتانز في ايران واغتيال المشرف
على البرنامج النووي الايراني لفخري
وانضم الينا من ولايه مينا الامريكيه
المنتج فيلم
قندهار المصور في العلا كيف تقيمها واين
تضع في المقندهار بين الافلام التي انتجها
اسكت لاستيتي
تجربه كانت رائعه في في تصوير الفيلم
بالعلب ثمانيه اشهر في السعوديه كان وقت
جميل واستمتعتوا
كان تحديا سواه من الافلام لكننا حصلنا
على دعم كبير من هيئه مختلفه حكوميه اتت
لمساعدتنا وكانت تجربتنا رائعه
بالنظر الى ما خرجنا به كفيلم فاز نحن
سعداء بما انتجناه
واجهه مفاجات وكانت تجربه فعلا جميله جدا
بتصوير الفيلم هناك
التسهيلات والدعم الانتاجيه المطلوبه
لتوفرت لك في العلا سيد اسكت
من الامور التي استمتعت بها كثيرا وكذلك
مساعدي هو في البدايه
تصوير الفيلم في السعوديه كان
ليس في الفتره التي كنا فيها بل هناك
تسهيلات وموارد وكنا بحاجه الى فريق ذو
خبرك
اعجبتني يا حقيقه اننا هناك اقلنا شراكه
مع شركائنا السعوديين وخرجنا بشيء جديد
لم تكن هناك كثير من التسهيلات في العلا
لكن الان هناك يبنون حاليا
مسرح صوت لكن في وقت تصوير الفيلم لم يكن
هناك شيء
استخدمنا موقع وهو بيت صغير
استخدمناه
والارض كانوا شركاء لنا
وساعدونا في وهي الهيئه الملكيه التي
ساعدتنا في تصوير الفيلم وبعض المعدات
التي لم تكن موجوده لكن هذا لكنها الان
اصبحت موجوده وكنا بحاجه لدعم لمساعده
للندخل المعدات والكوادر وحتى الطاقم وكان
من المهم ان نرى هذا الحماسه
شاهدناه من الكوادر التي انطمت انضمت
للعمل معنا كثير منهم بده خبره وقطر لم
يكن لديهم الخبره بل تعلموا معنا كانت
رحله جيده في العلا ساعدنا بها وكسبنا
خبره ويسرنا ان نقوم بهذه التجربه مره
ثانيه وكانت
تجربه مثيره وانا لدي فعلا لهف ان اقوم
بالتصوير مره ثانيه هناك
هل هناك اتفاق على فيلم على مسلسل او على
عمل في العلا قادم مستقبلي
شن
هناك حوار حالي
ليس لدي شيء محدد لكن هناك نقاش
وانا احب السعوديه واود ان اعود لصناعه
فيلم جديد هذا هدف لي هناك لنقاش لا
استطيع التحدث عن فيلم محدد لكن هناك نقاش
يدور الان حول افلام قادمه وهدفي هو
العوده والتصوير
لمزيد من الافلام في السعوديه
كمنتج لك خبره في الافلام السينمائيه لك
عده اعمال معروفه ايضا السيد
وهو ايضا واحد من اهم الاسماء في عالم
السينما ايضا الامريكيه
كيف تنظر الى السعوديه اليوم كواحد من
المناطق
واول العلا ايضا في صناعه الافلام في
صناعه السينما العالميه اين يمكن ان تقع
ان تضعها يعني
للغايات اعتقد ان السعوديه مؤهله جدا لان
تكون
مقصد الاول لصناعه الافلام في المنطقه
اولا لان هناك محفزات تقدم من الدوله
للافلام للافلام الجيده
والمحفزات
لصناعه الافلام جيده في العالم لكنها في
السعوديه منافسه جدا وافضل من اي محفزات
اخرى في اي مكان اخر لذلك هذا امر يستقدم
صانع الافلام وامر ثاني وهو
تنوع البيئه في السعوديه
شكل المنطقه في العلا قلاب جدا
وكذلك يمكن بناء المواقع مواقع التصوير
بشكل مختلف وبشكل متنو
وبالتالي فهي ليست مساله
لتقييم العلا لشكلها فقط بل يمكن ان تصنع
هذه الاشكال على مواقع التصوير
صورنا ايضا في جده وهي مدينه حيويه ويمكن
هذا ان
يضاف للمواقع التصوير ارى مستقبلا لتصوير
الافلام في السعوديه وهناك امور ذكيه تتم
الان وهناك
منتجين اذكياء محليين يقومون ببناء هذه
القاعده لصناعه الافلام بوسعي القول ان
المنطقه ستصبح بتاكيد مقصدا لصناعه
الافلام وانا مهتم بان اشاهد كيف ستتطور
هذه
الصناعه في السعوديه وكما رقبتها في انحاء
اخرى في العالم
على السعوديه لتضع
نفسها في خارطه الانتاج السينمائي العالمي
دعني يعني اسالك عن الفيلم من ناحيه فنيه
نقديه وهنا ربما يستعرض لك جزء من مقاله
هي ناقده دراميه رئيسيه في نيويورك تايمز
تحدثت وقالت بان وصفت هذا الفيلم بانه
فيلم ممل فيلم بطيء بشكل مذهل هذه في
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وان بتلر في هذا الفيلم اختار وسيره غير
فعاله القصه غير متماسكه دراميا احد
النقاد العرب يقول مثلا بانه هذا الفيلم
ليس فيه جديد باظهار رجل الاستخبارات
الامريكيه الرجل الخارق للعاده الذي يعني
تتنافس عليه الكثير من الدول للامساك به
كما حصل في قندهار ولكنها لم تفلح مثل هذه
الرؤى النقديه
يعني الى اي مدى تؤثر في الفيلم وخاصه في
الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في قبول او عدم قبول هذا هذا
الفيلم
الوقت
هو الكفيل عفوا بان يخبرنا هذه الاجابه
واعتقد انه بكل فيلم نراه سيكون هناك نقاد
من كلا الطرفين من يعجبهم من لا يعجبهم
هذا النقد الذي ذكرته انا سمعته وانهم
كانوا يتوقعون من الفيلم ان يكون عباره عن
اكشن مستمر
لا يتوقف لكن ان اردنا عمقا بالفلم لن
تكون هناك حركه طوال الوقت
المساله في صناعه الافلام ان هناك دائما
من
يعجبهم ومن لا يعجبهم هذا امر طبيعي شكرا
جزيلا لك
منتج فيلم
من ولايه من الامريكيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات